ja willkommen zurück hier bei Bild live
und es waren wirklich dramatische Szenen
die sich hier vor wenigen Minuten
abgespielt haben Bild Vize Paul
ronsheimer Gerät in Kiew unter Beschuss
hier sehen wir die Bilder eben mitten in
unserer Seite ja offenbar getroffen von
iranischen Kamikaze Drohnen mitten in
der Hauptstadt mehrere Häuser werden
zerstört Paul und sein Team die müssen
sich natürlich sofort in Sicherheit
bringen und wir schauen noch mal auf
diese Minuten unserer Live-Schalte
heute morgen 7 Uhr 12 bild-vize Paul
Ronzheimer berichtet live aus Kiew ich
gucke mich gerade oben war gerade eben
hat es hier wieder Schüsse gegeben
Luftverteidigungssystem
ja
plötzlich Explosion in unmittelbarer
Nähe wer kann sucht Schutz in einem
Hauseingang
ja die neue Angriff
ja es hat gerade zwei weitere Angriffe
hier genau an der Stelle gegeben an der
wir waren mit Kamikaze drohen wir haben
dann das Maschinengewehr Feuer gehört
was man auch in der Szene sieht gerade
eben mussten wir hier Schutz suchen an
dieser Stelle und dann erneut eine
heftige Explosion ein Einschlag die
Druckwelle hier zu spüren die Menschen
haben sich hier auf den Boden gelegt um
sich zu schützen davor
und es ist immer wieder damit zu rechnen
sozusagen dass hier nicht weit entfernt
ist weitere Angriffe geht weil ich zeige
euch einmal hier wie es hier aussieht ja
wir sehen hier das war gerade eben
dieser der Einschlag den es gegeben hat
und wir sehen hier oben der
Smok der Comic ist der von dieser Seite
kommt das ist eine ganz frische
drohneneinschlag von kamikazedonen von
iranischen Drohnen hier auf die
ukrainische Hauptstadt man sieht wie
sich zivile Gebäude in Rauchen wir gehen
jetzt mal wieder an diese Stelle in
diese Richtung wenn wir das können ist
der waistruh
und schauen
ja jetzt scheint es wieder in Ordnung zu
sein momentan zumindest das ist dieser
Situation wir sind hinter mir den
Hauptbahnhof und dann in die linke Seite
in diese Richtung
dort hat es diese Angriffe gegeben wir
gehen einmal in diese Richtung weiter
rein ich zeige euch das noch einmal wir
sehen hier Presse wir sind dort eben den
Hauptbahnhof
wieder ein Angriff in unmittelbarer Nähe
ja es gab eine erneute
erneuten
Angriff in diesem Moment offenbar und
das ist die Situation
wie es Menschen hier in Kiew geht
ja wir erleben hier Panik bei den
Menschen natürlich in diesem Moment
große Angst davor was als Nächstes
passieren kann weil es hat mehrere
Angriffe von diesen kamikazedonen eben
gegeben hier die reingeflogen kommen man
hört den Sound dieser Drohnen die
reinkommen und dann die Druck
okay also sie waren jetzt in diesem
Moment vor weiteren Drohnen die jetzt
hier
Kiew angreifen können und
das ist die Kriegssituation hier in Kiel
ja
wenig später Bild Vize Paul ronsheimer
erneut auf der Straße er will zeigen was
passiert ist in der Ferne Dichte
rauchschwagen
wieder das Geräusch einer anfliegenden
Drohne wieder sucht Deckung wer kann wir
müssen noch einmal hier Schutz suchen in
diesem Moment
hat dann weiterhin Angriff gegeben wir
müssen jetzt hier noch mal kurz suchen
und melden uns
melden uns gleich noch einmal zurück ja
[Musik]
ja unfassbare Szenen Paul du bist jetzt
zum Glück in Sicherheit wir haben gerade
gesehen viereinhalb Minuten wie du immer
wieder Schutz suchst vor den
heranfliegenden Drohnen das ist jetzt
circa eine Stunde her mit ein bisschen
Abstand wie blickst du jetzt auf diese
Bilder wie hast du das ganze erlebt
ich glaube in diesem Bildern zeigt sich
der ganze Terror der gegen die
ukrainische Bevölkerung entfacht wird
von Russland mit diesen Kamikaze Drohnen
die vom Iran an Russland geliefert
wurden es sind eben nicht mehr
ausschließlich Raketen sondern diese
Drohnen und wir haben live selbst
gesehen wie schwierig es ist für die
ukrainische Armee diese Drohnen zu
attackieren bevor sie einschlagen und
ich glaube es ist deshalb so wichtig
diese Bilder auch zu zeigen und ist
deshalb so wichtig dass Reporter dort
vor Ort waren wir sind ja nicht die
einzigen die dort waren sondern auch
andere Reporter um diesen Terror
authentisch zu transportieren und zu
zeigen wie dramatisch die Situation für
viele Ukrainer jeden Morgen an einem
ganz normalen Montagmorgen wo die
Menschen zur Arbeit fahren wo Menschen
ankamen am Hauptbahnhof in Kiel wo viele
Nachtzug genommen haben aus dem Westen
um dann in Kiew anzukommen und gehen
dort aus dem Hauptbahnhof hören das
Gewehr vorher hören die Explosionen
hören die Drohnen Angriffe das ist ein
Angriff für vitality Klitschko sagt auf
die zivile Infrastruktur es ging
offenbar erneut darum
ein Gebäude zu treffen was im
Zusammenhang mit dem
Heizkraftwerken steht Russlands ziel ist
es offenbar dafür zu sorgen dass große
Teile der ukrainischen Bevölkerung im
Winter keine Möglichkeit haben zu heizen
und das ist offenbar auch das Ziel
dieser kamikazedonen dieses Angriffs
gewesen Paul lass uns noch mal über
diese drohenden sprechen warum ist es so
viel schwieriger sie abzufangen warum
sind die so gefährlich
die Drohnen sind erst seit kurzem im
Einsatz der Iran hat erst vor Jahr
wenigen Monaten bekannt gegeben auch
dass man diese eben an Russland liefert
und die Ukraine scheinen sich noch nicht
darauf richtig eingestellt zu haben auch
was die Luftverteidigung angeht die
Luftverteidigung hatte sich vor allem
konzentriert eben auf marshmallowkörper
auf Raketen was ja zum großen Teil eben
das war was hier immer in diesem Krieg
eingesetzt wurde aber die
Luftverteidigung gegen kamikazedonen ist
komplexer und schwieriger und wir sehen
wie er ukrainische Soldaten da fast
verzweifelt versuchen mit
Maschinengewehren diese Drohnen vom
Himmel zu holen das klappt er schlecht
als recht einige sollen getroffen worden
sein also es hätte wohl noch viel mehr
Angriffe gegeben von Drohnen aber andere
treffen eben ihre Ziele in dem Fall ein
Gebäude gegenüber das haben wir dort
dann erlebt dass diese Explosion
passierte da scheint es einige Treffer
zu geben statt jetzt aber ist es so dass
die dass das Wärme gerade Heizkraftwerk
beziehungsweise das Wärme Zentrum dort
nicht getroffen wurde also es noch
zumindest keine Gefahr dafür gibt
das komplette Heizsysteme ausfallen Paul
nimm uns noch einmal mit was nach dieser
schalt nach diesen viereinhalb Minuten
passiert ist wie konntest du sozusagen
flüchten du bist jetzt wieder im Hotel
und ja wie ist die Lage jetzt vor allem
es waren ja nicht nur vier Minuten
sondern wir haben immer wieder
unterbrochen in diesen live-schalt ich
glaube wir waren fast ja eine halbe
Stunde oder Stunde dort vor Ort ich
verliere so ein bisschen die Zeit dabei
es ist so dass wir versucht haben immer
wieder die Konsequenzen dieses Kamikaze
Terrors zu zeigen und es lief meistens
so ab wie Journalisten haben versucht
dort eben zu fotografieren zu filmen was
eben unser Job ist und dann in ja
innerhalb von Sekunden hat dann haben
dann Soldaten Polizisten gebrüllt in
Deckung gehen die sind dann wie man auch
in dem Video sieht gerannt wir sind auch
gerannt und haben dort dann in einem
Haus Deckung gesucht einige haben sich
direkt auf den Boden gelegt denn man
weiß ja nie sozusagen welche Teile
Splinter welche
uns und andere dort eben hätten treffen
können ja man sieht in diesem Moment die
tatsächliche Panik das sind ja nicht
alles
Soldaten oder Polizisten oder auch
Reporter die solche Situationen schon
erlebt haben im Anwohner die dort neben
meinem Leben und ich habe eine Frau
gesehen auch kurz davor in einem
Hausflur die dort da vor ihrer Tür lag
und
vor Panik geweint hat weil sie dachte
dass wir in ihre letzten Minuten
[Musik]